Že jo, že myslím, že 2 měsíční review.
Proto jsme si to ovšem vybavilo,
to perfektní,
tak teďka jako navážem s tím,
že tady poprosím teprve přeskočíme teda
KPI, nechceš k tomu něco říct?
KHP asi přeskočíme.
Nebo chceš maličkost?
Řekni si to je fajn,
já jenom produkt pravděpodobně,
někdy jsou tam vlastně vyplněný.
Z tohohle tejga tady něco chybí.
Já bych možná na začátku Ondru klidně
poprosil,
aby jestli to okomentuješ kvality a.
Produktivitu.
A.
Potom jenom braeflowe vám se posunuly ty
jednotlivé projekty?
Se posuly ty projekty za poslední měsíc.
Tak.
Tam se posuly projekty skončíme a potom
vás poprosím asi tradičně ty milníky,
které vás čekají k 1.
Ten květen asi bude k 1.
Červen budou asi hodně náročnej,
tam to bude některý věci finanšovat,
že jo, dodělávky a podobně.
A tam většinou vždycky vznikaj takový ty
různý linky, takže teďka je tak,
že si řekneme,
jaký maník vás čekají a potvrdíme si tady
zítra, jestli teda nějaký teda stává,
se to nebo, který myslíte,
že pravděpodobně asi tam nastanou jo,
takže takže to se stalo nějaký uhlíky a
případně problémy, který čekáte,
abychom tady slyšeli,
na budete mít nějak nějak postavit?
Tak já se tady potřebuji teda připojit to
beru.
Bylo totiž připojené stan tý psané nejseš.
Bylo to nepříjemné, připojím se.
A promítám právě třeba jinak.
Tady jsem ale.
Tak.
Jak to rychle ještě nebo k vám děkuju,
pojď ještě doplňte i tak.
Jinak teda Filip nebude tam.
Asi tady za Filip ano?
Ok, aby to Lukáše.
I dneska to lidi tím pádem asi nebude ty
projekty pro pryč.
I tak si užijem potom tak.
Ondro vidíš účtování to rád jo on se má.
Tam tady připojovat jo,
ale tak taková ta roční pro expedici,
čas vozu a tak dále kláštery.
Děkuji už tady ty 2.
Čtvrtek.
Koletoroční doručení je 90.
34.
Tak.
Tak třeba tak chvilka doči.
Jako vezměme od toho týdne jak jak jako
průřez, kterýho to měsíce.
Tak na tadydle tady z těch tejdnech je
nejsem připravený prostě.
Když to vezmu.
Politická expedice sympatii začíná jako
velice stoupat.
Tam, kde furt ještě vnímám problematiku,
tak jsou nepřekvapivě crossy.
Což je pro mě strašně velkej vykřičník
pohledu systémovej dep.
Je to pro mě strašně zabezpečný.
Teď to neutypickej problém kvality
kvalita expedice.
Prašťany počká.
Vlastně jako nemáme vůbec pokrytý,
jestli to auto nebo špatně.
Řeším teď s dopravama,
protože oni jako jejich 1 vytaje,
jdeme se kouknout na kamervená kamerové
záznamy lomeno v podstatě GPS.
Versus abysme řekli kvalita příjmů
soudného listu cokoliv jako balíku joby a
tak dále. To je velký téma,
který se pohledu 400 systémovejch dob je
fakt jako velkej velkej travel.
Stále tam nemáme nic.
Pod kontrolou a vlastně říká i kvalita
expedice na přímky distribuce je dobrá v
té době za 4% dost často.
Je to způsobený v krátkodoběma výpadkama,
podle případně interakce s dopravama.
Hrozný příjezd, plotný odjezd a tak dále.
A 2 věc to bylo, to bylo.
Dobrý den až.
Na jakejkoliv změnách.
Neexistuje.
Paleta kvality na změnu neexistuje.
Rozměna se rozhodl.
Jo,
tohle to vlastně vůbec nemáme podchycený.
Jak už nikde.
Včera Miroslav.
Věta,
jakože týden máme problém s nějakými
nastavením jako furt jenom dohledáváme.
Měl,
přirovnal bych to skoro já jako s vývojem
it i furt objevujeme bugy bugy.
Ale tam se bavíme jakože na
standardizovanejma je podprocesama a
složitejma.
Nastavováním slovu jako není úplně jako
jednoduchá věc,
ale slyším to tedy 3 roky 7 let.
A říkáme, jenom implikujeme, komplikujeme,
komplikujeme žádné automatizace 0 ta to
je 1 velký téma,
který tady je částečně až v rámci těch
systémů je.
V rámci expedice.
Performance.
Tam jsem.
Nemile překvapenej jak jak jak málo máme
v řízení na paletu lomeno svozový listy.
Ten pick.
Tam je velký pro mě.
Teď potenciál toho musel tam posunout.
V rámci efektivity mizíš kolik kde
třídíme palata,
kolik procent máme předpiku? Jo,
což je dost spojený a pochopil jsem,
že úzký místo je je naopak.
Protože efektivita vytahováků nemůžeme
dát dopřetiku, jelikož nemáme předpik,
máme špatně napečované bedny.
Nemůžeme je přijít na paletu takhle jako.
Jednoduše zřetězený má už 50% 50% jobin
ten big 70.
65%.
By jako mělo pokrejt všechny debaty,
není to tak.
OK.
Sice.
Tam.
Pro vod 24.
Tam vlastně od včerejška jsme konečně
zapnuli nějaký to.
To grosování se to chytalo v průběžném
tím svodů.
Já taky ano 1 den dělá to nějaký zvláštní
věci.
U mě.
To, co když se koukám do budoucnosti?
Nevím jak moc tenhleten o tom neví.
Budeme.
Právě z pohledu.
U evahu přesouvat výrazně víc objemů bylo
HPP lidí.
Důvodů přesunů dodávek služeb na agenturu
práce, která je výrazně dražší.
To znamená,
má cenu ABP zaměstnanců a ta hra z toho,
jakoby pěkně?
Co nejdřív počet z provozu na dneska tady
máš 4000 hodin na který jako utilizovat.
To znamená někde v atevování.
Pavel.
Což bude nová, respektive pro celý.
A jenom jako tím switchem se budeme bavit
o hudba a 200 miliónech korun,
který tenhleten rok těch mezd narveme.
Plus říkáme,
že to bysme měli pod kreditou a také.
Tam už to není jako stejný efektivity.
Máme na to dopadlosti účtů.
A.
Když máme tohleto, to je věc 1.
To je jako relativně funguje.
Během posledního tejdne udělali 50
nabídek.
Je dejme tomu.
Asi.
A co se HPP je?
300 357 krytím 50 ti lidí,
aby jsme měli představu, jako je krychle,
se nám to dá dokáže nabrat.
Tak jsou to čeští filipníci.
A je to pro tento procent,
tak už máte bene.
Maximum.
Jako není to je to o tom agentura,
kde nám dává flexibilitu,
ale flexibilitu ne jako ty horní hraní,
když budou stát jako o 30% stropu než náš
směr.
Jo.
To je jako hlavní číslům tím hlavní výzva.
Investory.
Aby se nám ne abysme byli rádi.
A, jako je to vlastně mimo to téma,
které točili.
Těma jsou jako těma.
Tohleto je jakoby.
Tak ano poslední věc,
co jsme si otevřeli s heinkem,
jsou ty idlety.
Jako prostoje,
který potřebujem začít jakoby zjistit
ověřím,
že se nám to podaří skrze aristotelovi.
Co neví třeba aristotel.
Novej docházkovej systém.
Kterej dokáže řídit tyto věci,
které dneska samozřejmě děláme a
dorunujeme,
ale tenhle ten systém nám to popvělí
takový věci jako napočítávání,
přes času takový věci jako dodržování
nebo možnosti využívání salt a docházce.
Někdy tenhle měsíc v tom 130 hodin a
následují měsíc dokáže opracovat víc.
Zároveň nám to dohlídá přes.
Časy.
Průměru 8 hodin přes času týdně po dobu
kolik 20 týdnů v řadě.
Já vám příjemně.
To jsou a jestli,
protože jsem slyšel banky zpátky třeba i
nějak tady.
Jo jo jo OK jinak ano produktivita na
úrovni 43 to co myslím že to je dosaditel.
Aktuálním nastavení.
Pokud ne,
pokud nemáme nějaký dispropodce na příjmu.
A během 6 měsíce se z toho stane 47 a půl.
Toto play.
Takže tam by měla bejt změna tohoto
přesně tak, ale jenom cílená.
Je to prostě díky tomu,
že sebereme 47 lidí denně z Drážďan a
přesune.
Ta produktivita tak jak kolísa tak
vlastně kolísá s výplatníma výplatníma
termínem, platí to.
Ču to z toho správně?
Jo čtu jsou to správně,
zvláště 3 jako 120000 mínus tak se tam
dostaneme do zakázaného slova provozní
minimum.
Ty musíš rozšířit 1 znova se vracím k těm
všem jako akciím,
což je roztřídit tolik a tolik bedýnek.
Ať už je to jako 180 100 140000.
Já tam jako končí nějaké výnosy z rozsahu.
Sám.
Zajímavý.
Tak promiňte asi všechno. Fakt to vypadá,
že to jde. Potom děkujeme pěkně,
budu připraveni. Já myslím,
že tohle bylo dobrý jako neočekával,
že bude fakt o bodu spíš nějak jako orol
orol za tebe.
Okomentovat ty kvality,
on se spíš denně tato produktivitu,
protože v tom sedí denně.
Poslední možná věta posledních pár dní se
nám nejen úplně dařily trh oba v depline.
165 170 182000 včerejška,
a to se ještě on se protáhnout.
Pro jestli to je obratem,
jestli to je kde ten opravdu.
Co to je problém jako dregafázování?
A zároveň teďka nakonec skončili úplně
proland, že práškem jako zhruba řeknu.
Chodit do večera od večera do půlnoci.
Kolik procent objevil,
napadá objednávek power grist od 8.
Tancově je to 520 až 30% 30 ae.
Máme furt máme už 35 taky.
5 je teď právě Slovenska a bylo to 5%
posledních každou hodinu,
takže nějakých 22 20% Slováci do čech je
33 a nějaké riziko, které?
Široce potřebuju.
OK.
Děkujeme.
Tak jo můžu na projekty při teda
fungování dotaz na Ondru to bylo d andu.
Tam nevidím kdykoliv žádný jako velkej
game changer vysloveně,
kterej jako corneo odeslání reverzního
distiky. Jo,
ale je tam hromada těch jako drobnejch
věcí, který potřebujem jako cvičit.
Vy jste před tej za cenu martine dopadli
tohleto už s tebou vyřešili,
že bysme na hodinu začali jako používat v
pikovací boty jako vytahováky.
V rámci hodiny využít tu kapacitu bot to
vytlačit.
A pomoct si teďkon ta nickhicat až bude
celý vytahovat.
Takovýhle věci teďkon.
I za ceny těm 43,
respektive zvýšit tu efektiitu.
Protože 200 milionů.
Nečekat.
Klidně říct, to by se muselo stát teď,
jak bychom to mohli zase.
Modro odeslání si myslela toho sdělování
před.
Pojďme velmi krátce.
Raději za vás posun za poslední měsíc
tome.
No co se týče i trasu,
tam teda pořád platí, že?
To mi nekonečně.
Teda nárůst je jenom, jak to je odškod.
Obecně jako problematika je krytuje v tom,
že ve chvíli,
kdy kdy je to crossová položka,
tak se tím nezapočítává do je tratu ani
negativně, ani pozitivně.
Tím pádem všechny expor,
ve které krosujeme přes chráše nebo přes
divy, tak jsou vyjmutý z hytry tu úžic.
Takže to neumějem měřit v tuhle chvíli
plapy chlapi dává dohromady tenhle věku.
No co se týče.
Respektive skladování tak tam.
Řekněme,
že ten poslední měsíc je takový kolísavý.
Co se týče krášťan, tam se to drží.
To není těch 54%, což je vlastně.
Tak nějak ostatní v rámci celého toho
projektu.
A Tomáš ty nějaké výkyvy to znamená třeba
na 51.
Ale spíš to většinou bylo z důvodu ňákých
jako změn, co se týče.
Toho ten struktury toho skladu nějaké
nějaké části toho skladu, co se týče LCU.
Ten měsíc,
nebo respektive předešlých měsíc.
Taky takový staly párkrát směrem dolů.
Teď aktuálně jména 57 procentech ten CA.
Což je pořád nějaký lepší,
než byl vlastně do startu,
ale měli jsme být jen na 60 procentech,
takže.
Je to takové kolik se?
Pro proč tam jako ten jak vidím jako že
jsme se nahledou pak jsme se vrátili zase
zpátky jako nulový posun?
Abysme byli.
Spadli z 60 z 58 na těch 55.
Snažil jsem se dopátrat.
Já jsem se jako přímo.
Má tu otázku od našeho nějakou se nevrací
odpověď ta zablokovaná plošina,
která se teprve teď na díky koloudaci
bude používat, to i nebo není.
V respektive to využívá?
Být mimo.
Filozofii horní,
když jsem tam byl naposled.
2 týdny zpátky tak bylo ještě mimo.
Takže nevím teďka aktuální 2 týdnech ale.
Ještě nedávno bylo platidlo,
že se používá jenom to trhu.
Chápu to nebylo započítané,
protože ve chvíli,
kdy tady blokadovaný žádný produkt,
tak to ne aby.
Tak potom další.
To jsou ty grossy.
Prosím mezi krátkýma užicemi a tam.
Tam se držíme teďka.
Co se týče těch expedičních přesunů mezi
krátce doma už více, má tam ta cíl,
jako že se pod to teďka za vlastně minulý
měsíc jsme víceméně pořád disponujeme.
Takže.
Co se týče potom už nějaké role toho l 17
a co se týče expedičních jogů?
Tam jako plošně na XKO už jsme téměř 190
procentech, konkrétně to teďka je 89.
Co se týče zásoby,
tam už jsme na 90 procenty.
Teď je to necelých 92.
Co se týče toho XP 8 a kterého se týkalo
vlastně to samotné stěhování,
to tady není tam vidět tak tam.
Nám zbývá oproti původním řekněme 4000.
Nějakých řekněme posledních 1000 CCH,
takže.
Už se jako blížíme.
Necháme ten výprodeji,
ale už se jako blížíme poměrně jako silně
k hranici,
kdy už jako ten zbytek bude minimální.
Ale pořád se držíme toho,
že už jsme dokonce.
To je to co budu malovat teda.
Ale připadalo to zpomaluje je to.
Je to vývoj,
že už ten pokles není tak razantní
logicky, jak bylo. Třeba se zeptám,
co s jakým autem odvážíme?
Co náš tím to jede přímo do directema?
Jo jo jo ty tam nejsou žádný.
O co bylo na začátku?
Začátku termín 80% podeláme z růžic,
který vám na nějakejch posledních 10%.
Toho malého exportu,
když prezert za chrášťan.
A co se týká tý zásad?
Tak je to velmi dobrý posledních 20%
zásoby,
kterou jsme původně drželi na chrášťany.
Zbytek už je.
V kužicích to znamená tohleto už nám.
To to 1.
Nebo.
Expert distribuce no to jsem chtěl ještě.
Tam jsem si všiml,
že za poslední 2 týdny nebo respektive 3
začalo lehce stoupat a.
Něco tam mění jako úplně v pořádku.
Ne,
nepodařilo se mi dostat se k nějakému
jako.
Cup.
Východy by šlo vidět,
třeba by jsme v průběhu toho času.
Nechtěně třeba.
Přijali.
By mělo 1 Drážďan tak ho jako toho toho
drášťa ne porušujou jako pravidlo nebo
jejich mám nic.
Jeví se to tak, že do těch krášan?
Teďka v nějakém jako zbytečném objemu.
To se začalo jezdit IS tou, které.
SPD.
Nestihli jsme to s nima otočit za 3 dny.
Ano.
OK.
Ano.
Jako na začátku toho projektu jsem byli
na nějakých 70 denně.
K tomu není tohle jako nemá cenu
komentovat. Jo, jako prostě 3 tejdny,
tak jako dneska,
prosím tě kohokoliv tady na tomhle patře,
když jsme a jako co se děje,
to kontroluje, že by to kontrolovalo,
že to tady děláte.
Kolik? Takže tam jsme dávali nějakej čas,
jo, kdy jsme říkali.
Představuje a stále se to,
že a ono se to stalo.
Ono se to stalo a pak to zase pustili.
To je od té doby,
co tam není Martina draba.
Tak je to za spuštěný,
takže potřebujeme to dostat na peepa nebo
na Horáčka.
Ale tome je našli diskuze,
to jsem ti říkal.
Poprvé se tam do žižků tak ti vytvoří
nějaké forting, kde budou jasně dané,
kde budou jasně Daniel tím objednávky,
podle čeho to můžeme kontrolovat?
Jinde prostě jako zodpovědnost.
Hele každej trvalo mi to 3 měsíce každá
akce, když jsem je posílal,
printscreen dámy a pánové a za dny
produkty do 50 korun jsou na webu.
Ano trvalo to při 3 měsíce,
ale každou akci každej 1 den akce se mi
to psal.
Tady každej den prostě včera vesla na
tolikatohy, tady jsou SP říky.
Prostě nadšíme tam bejt.
Oni jsou my 3 ve vyjednáváních.
Oni budou schopni sedět a je to jejich
práce. Je to jejich práce.
Dobrý den, přeskočil tam k těm testům,
asi není co dodat. To si,
když tak řekneme,
v průběhu těch reportů ten čech slyšeli?
No jo, to pojďme si to říct.
Dopravníkkou síť teď asi taky nemá smysl
komentovat.
Vytahování se drží ve stejných tak nemá.
Ne tedy ne možná jen možná,
prosím tě rema.
C.
Já bych to nechal potom na ty na ty tady
jenom pojďme prolítnout ty boky data a
pak skočíme na ty pak skočíme na ty
reporty jo.
Robot je jich možná martine poprosím tě
vývoj roboků za poslední měsíc v rámci v
rámci těch DPI čech. Co se týče KPI,
jsme teď to budou určitě.
Vzali si to řeknu až takový projektový
semeni a externě nejsou VAPI.
A tak se o tříčtinu bych vytvařovala,
co jsem se David.
Tam to bylo o tom,
že jsem potom další 1 už najel,
protože tam bylo to předávací ten
předávací den pomáhá.
Proč jste vlastně skočil 93 robotiků? Jo,
tam jsme spočili a lidi k tomu předávací
email 10 let.
Kolikrát.
Znamená přijelo a splnil se ta skro.
Skončil robot sám o sobě ne odeslovače
dobře.
Pardon.
Mám se teďkon ptát,
proč se nám nezměnila i.
Ty super ta kvalita.
Jo, rozumím,
že tady by to mělo bejt dost spojený.
Pochopil jsem,
že rychlost jako pohybování robota už je
jako stabilní a jako dobrá a jediný,
co nás blokuje, tak jsou jako záseky.
Ano.
Další části za mě Martina jo.
Tady je podle mě jako velkej otazník,
to jak tady byla,
jak tady byla ta kvalita,
teda ta rekordní hodnocovaná, protože tím,
že jste to nějaký testovací období,
kdy se chvilku jelo chvilku najelo
chvilku jelo chvilku najelo,
tak jestli se to dalo vyhodnocený jenom
jako v době, kdy to jelo a bylo tam 230,
tak chápu, že teď,
když to měřilo takhle celej den,
přile mě 185, protože ty kabilita 93%.
Předtím ta pikabilita do toho třeba
nebyla započta a tohle to bych chápal a
takhle já to jako vidím.
Toho i vlastně z toho, co mi říkal Filip,
že to takhle jako bylo,
protože vlastně do té doby,
co to pojede v provozu,
tak bych začal koukat na tu souvislost
mezi pikabilitou a respektive na picoval.
A 2 vyklezuju si k poctví? Já si myslím,
že tobě.
Bude jako správně,
do týhle doby to bylo hodně,
protože to jelo přerušování a měřilo se
to tak jako do výšky. I tam jako vidím 3.
Teď už ukazatel,
to je nějaká jako průměrná doba příchodu
manažera na schůzku.
Na doba, kdy nám jako trvá ta oprava.
S tou efektivitou respektive.
Jo,
ale je to na to je o to store velmi
rychle.
Už to dokážeme odlohovat a je to hodně
krát a nebo nám to trvá dlouho.
Protože člověk mi přijde,
nebo to jako jsou složitý věci.
Praha.
Tady.
Kterými se prostě těhle těch čísel
dokážeme takhle jako vyčíst.
Jo, protože jsem pochopil,
teď to bude upravit člověk,
kterej ta bude chodit do tý platby
primárně tak jestli David ahoj davide.
Jsme rádi, že sis udělal dovolenou.
A nebo ne? Tady to bylo.
To je dostatečný národ rozbetlování.
Jestli se nepozvoli z 52% jenom.
91.
Hele co se týče té deskau že jo je 52.
My jsme to měli z těch původních 95.
Vzhledem k tomu,
že spousta lidí jsou původní z původní
prede, chceme vycházela dobře, protože.
Hlavní materiál,
případně špatný výpadek a tak dále jsme
to snižovali,
když jsme ji zvýšili bezpečnost kopieru.
Jo, ale samozřejmě Filip,
já jsem toho nich přebíral tento Filip
týden v podstatě,
já to probíhá to předání.
Já to než tady to design potom.
Mě napadá jenom poslední věc toto.
Tedy pod.
01-05.
Ví, jak máte spletňovat možnost?
Že se šlo vykovat.
Kolik těch mailů je na novejch
objednávkách a kolik je na starejch?
Jestli to bude důležitý jako dávat tady
zpětnou vazbu,
děláme to blbě na příjmu stálé a nese
bičovat a říkat si. No víš,
co ještě počkáš jako měsíc a to na to.
Ono se to zlepší a.
U se mnou Martina prosím okomentuj
dokumentu o prst se vezmu se ti neměl
bažant a co se týče auto sporu,
mám to nějaký 2 3 důležitý milník to mám
mildy.
Především asi pro Ondra prodejova jo za
prvý,
když porovnáme spolehlivu z autospodu UP
4 korun ZP jednička,
tak jsme vymýšleli up time logu procentní
oborů. Co to pro vás znamená?
Máme o 50% i na měsíc AO 50% kratší
kratší to od stávku toho průzkumu na
měsíc, takže jsme zvýšili o spolehlivost.
Dostupnost, snížili jsme dobu,
jak jsme reaguje na to pivo.
A následně budeme prominovat odezvu 70%,
že 1. Epidemie se napofi budou.
Začínáme reagovat tím,
že tam budeme s těmi servis.
Čili to zpráva pro kluky,
že na tohle hodně teďka pracujeme v vašem
kongriálu, aby o tom věděli?
To je 1. Podle mě důležitá věc 2.
Důležitá věc.
Od začátku roku jsme se rekubli,
vrátím zpátky.
Nevim, jestli tady chyby na měsíc,
kdyby mělo bejt,
jakože spíš chybina 100000.
Takže dost tam.
Jak jsme to probírali předáme,
protože tady to nedával jo, jako není to,
není to přímo. My dáme teďka,
určitě to tam má, určitě to má vliv.
Tak 2 důležitý.
Bod z prosince jsme rychlost typu v
průměru o 1,
8 sekundy dál do storu medián nebo nějaký
věci na 17 sekundy.
Když se na to podíváme,
grafově náměsíční trendy,
tak to má operytel renake mind.
To si představ jako do gitnovej vim
podobu,
než dokončíš se zase někdo někde přijede
min, nebo je zapnutá kontrola,
že můžou fungovat.
Aplikace dokuta a konzole OKOK tomu
pohodlně špínu přes lodě jsme byli na tom
byli na této operaci někde kolem v
průměru 9 a půl sekundy.
Teďka v dubnu jsme byli na nějakých 7,
7 sekund. Jo, je to vidět tady.
Na aktivitách se jim potvrzovali IZ
provozu, že museli upravovat.
Celkově se to promítá i do produktivity
typu,
která člen jako takovýho jsem si to
dneska stahoval nějaký data.
A co se týče spor o člověka průměrných na
tipů na man aury,
tak to máme 11% přes fotopay člověka man
aury se zmenšily o 6% a produktivita 100
gener of se zlepšila o 20%.
Je to za celý pěkný trval a postoje je už
jediný věk, jak je to vlivem podpořit.
Co je vliv pod tu pod co vliv pěkný,
že se zrychlili postup bota? Myslím,
že tam máte takový vliv. Vzhledem k tomu,
že ten průměr nebo ta rychlost spiknu
řekněme normální ABXA to ta klasická LT
tam víceméně nejsou až takové rozdíly,
nebo se tam nebude mít takový vliv.
Je to vyloženě tím, co jsme tam dělali.
Teďka za ty 3 měsíce, všechno za úpravy,
vylepšení obraz vedoucím a tak dál k tomu.
Když se každou 3 každej 3 pig nedělal
efektivní, vracel si zboží do bedny.
To přece musí být zrychlení.
Picconem picone to není pig,
to je potvrzení do bedny.
Tohle rychlost nebo jako manaworlds
jamenawars se ti to projeví?
A menu by se stan měl probíjet ano,
protože jako každej 3 bych mi děláš
efektivní, ale systémový nekne,
ale čas strávený na stadionu vlastně
nevyper zas počet picků jo by se tím měl
jako zlepšit,
protože tam nemá jako žáci jako báda.
Čekám na ten bin vkládám blbinu odjíždí.
Jsme tady 2 na 1 a teď se nehádejme se to
dává smysl tak asi jo jo jako co se týká
zrychlení tý produktivity domů,
zdrojový zdrojový nebo toho grafu co jste
tam ukazovala, tak ten je jako.
Ten je jasný to šlo jako doba těch vašich
optimalizací spíš teďka koukám na ty na
tu produktivitu na 1 Dublinu vlastně.
To tam tam nevím,
tam by to chtělo se podívat taky ne na
ten graf.
Proložit to, kdyby tím,
kdy jsme spustili exportu do portu a
vlastně jako dopočítat ten přepočítat ten
dopad to.
Tohle člověk asi do té KPI.
Osobně.
Výborně vracet.
To dělá někde v kódu,
tohle těch 5 kódo nemám na trhu strašně
rád před peníze.
OKA, bylo to hezký hezký.
Byl hezkej reportáž, jsou hezký výsledky.
Tak řekl bc RA pnout.
Pojďme teda na projekty konkrétně.
Ty se smithuju ty KPI.
Vlastně jako v hromadě jsme se nikam
neposunuli,
dostáváme stále stejně a já nevím.
Je to proto, že čekáme,
až se něco stane a nebo děláme různý
kroky,
ale ten výsledek se tam nezobrazuje.
Je to proto, že velká část těch projektů,
který tady vedeme, tak ještě nebyly,
ještě nejsou zrealizovaný,
jsou v přípravný fázi depa.
Reverská příjem a tak dále.
AU toho jsem já říkal,
že to přeskočit tam je tam,
kde už to je zrealizovaný,
tak jsme to probírali pro to úžitce pro
boty nezměněný robot.
Rozumím napsat, tam se bavím o tom,
že potřebujeme.
Celá Lenka doručení.
Tak to já teda přeskočím tyhlety 1 2.
Ty zásilky u 20 27. Příprav na ty funkční.
Provoz celkem 24 7 terko prosím tě.
Kapitola.
Tak jak už jsme se bavili několikrát,
nám se tam toho jakoby neděje.
Ale přesto se podařila nasadit změna ke
spravedl textu. To znamená,
chybám se aktuálně na nejvyšší možný
smyslu a podařilo se,
koho dost informace z dneška.
Navede.
Se povedlo.
Nevím, jako nevím dnešní výsledky,
ale ze včerejšek se nám to chytlo 1 svozu
druhýho ne ale rovnou.
Ta 1 dopadla na 3 nemáš náhodou informace?
Nemám na tom,
že jde konečně nasazený a teď tenkrát.
Jsme říkali několik týdnů.
Jako ta kolaudace to je ono to tady
zapadlo jo ale koloudovali jsme jako.
To.
To dlouhý době.
Jo to je velká velkej ko milní fakt jako
důležitej a potřebnej.
Ano.
Takže to je madlo se to cloud.
Je to dobrý uhnout máme.
Tak jo.
Takže.
Tak se něco zavedly,
rizika tam je ten den zmiňovány,
kolikrát se crosu schůzka dneska v
tomkrát dneska dneska, potom ještě.
Co nás tam čeká,
tak je vlastně přesunout ten zbytek těch
zásob, tak jsme se dopovili,
že zatím necháme běžet.
Na konci května si řekneme,
jak jsme na tom chráštěm tu plochu
nepotřebujou,
takže IZ důvodu nějakejch úspor za
dopravy necháváme zatím běžet tak,
jak to je.
A do třicátýho 6 zase probíhá výprodej
stev a měli bysme předtím 7.
Pokud se zase nedohodli nějak nějak?
Přemýšlím pro to.
A bude to tam bude, řekneme.
Tak já bych chtěla jako zeď ale ale.
Domaš tam dobře.
Bude to vaše určitě.
Takže.
To výš ten griot tak poprosím,
případně byste něco vědět, nebo?
Příjem pořád měří,
teda bydlel třeba výstupem je,
co je toho 250 nebo dalo bysme se o tom?
Jo, to je vlastně dneska.
Tak jo.
Otázky k tomuhle projektu nebo co se to
stalo?
Pravda.
Restrukce technologií a materiálů.
Chápu.
Destrukce to zásadní,
co jsou uplynuly měsíci odehrálo,
tak bylo to, že jsme se rozhodli,
že stroje,
které neumíme prodat jiným způsobem,
tak dáváme do aukce nebo rozeběhnem tu
akci s aukcí. Zároveň jsme se rozhodli,
že k tomu přidáme i obavový materiál,
kterému se neumíme zbavit a zároveň i ten
materiál,
který je rozesetej poskládek od techu.
Vybrali jsme i aukční portál.
To německá firma surc, nějak jsme s nima,
už zahájili jednání osobně řešíme teďka
smlouvu, máme tam připomínky,
ty jsou teď na jejich stranu hození a
čekáme. Doufám,
že tak třeba do příštího týdne,
my jsme ji,
nikdy bychom to mohli mít vyladěný a
podepsaný.
Zároveň teda tady k tomu,
jak už jsem naznačil,
připravujeme ten seznam strojů obalového
materiálu a toho materiálky.
Tím,
jak se to proflákává nebo prosakuje to
skrz firmu,
tak se občas ozývají některým oddělení,
jakože pobočky tady máme nějakej stroj,
můžeme zkusit prodat,
takže super chytá se to a myslím si,
že jako je to širší než jenom ze skladu.
Každopádně k těm milníkům,
jak jsem naznačil do patnáctýho 5,
chceme podepsat smlouvu s tím superxem
říkáme,
že do 1 6 bychom chtěli zahájit aukci.
A doufám, že to bude stihnutelný,
protože tam musí proběhnout ta akce.
Že přijedu nějakej její člověk,
ten to všechno nafotí nějakým
profesionálnějším,
profesionálnějším způsobem.
Pak se to zas po jednotlivé položky nebo
té nauce a tak dále.
Ukončení aukce říkáme,
že by mělo bejt do třicátýho 1 7.
Jsou v tom započítám 2. Kola aukce,
což superx navrhuje, jako že je správný,
protože se domnívá,
že po 1 korá asi všechno nedokážeme
prodat, ale stále platí to,
že 1 8 bychom chtěli mít vyprázdnění
skladeb těchto věcí.
Jak jsem říkal minule někdy budeme muset
říct, že ten den, kdy řežeme.
V podstatě to, co nedokážeme prodat,
být auto věděli.
Jo za míru prostě jednoznačně.
Pojďme se toho zbavit,
tak to tam už nepřekáží a ještě na
konečné služby tou němčině ta smlouva
řešíme. To se slovákem,
který má připravenou skoro českou verzi.
Je to takový,
no jsou tam nějaké chyby včas?
Rudolf.
Takže nda.
Jo,
ale nemluvíme o eurech jako celkově o
procentech.
Že oni by se to pak brát nějaké procenta
a tak dál.
Dobrý. Super.
Děkuju to na své všechno,
všechno otázky nekopletu.
Máte ještě vědět,
co by tam bychom mohli prodat?
Je to o něčem.
X prostě,
která mi hlásili do firmy tokol se dražší
než x já moc si krátký není to není to
omezený že to má bejt dražší než XS tím,
že máme hodně těch věcí,
který chceme konat,
takže to je zajímavý a můžeme přehazovat
v podstatě, co chceme.
Jako ty teda máme ředitelku poradu a tak
to tam prosím.
Tady možnost teďkon jo jako regály 1
regál vyprodat jo takhle klidně zkusme to
tam navodit,
oni třeba řeknou sami od sebe,
že to ani nemá.
Smysl dávat do té aukce,
protože mají tu zkušenost a navíc ještě
chci k tomu dodat.
Tady sice vidíš ondro nějaké termíny,
kdy to chcem zahájit,
ale chcem s nima podepsat smlouvu k
nějakému tu budem potom smlouvat,
abychom tu obci mluvili.
Mám a mám produkty, co mám dělat?
Mám tady jako speciální v tuhle chvíli,
ozvi se m je.
A až doděláme tenhle projekt,
tak vymyslíme, komu se obejmu.
Taky tam jsou podmínky,
nebo jako oni nám dávají garanci toho
prodeje nedají ty garanci to nedokážou
garancovat. To jako říkají,
že dokážou prodat skoro všechno,
a tak jako 80 nebo 8 d to.
By to určitě ne.
Souhlasím.
Jako.
Nevím, jestli mi dokážeme říct,
kolik to má mít hodnoty.
Necháváme to čistě na mi, říkáme,
kolik to stálo nákupka? Já to neříkám to.
Rešeruju, to je i sami, a my říkáme,
co je to za stroje,
jestli je to stroj novej,
nebo je to použitej stroj a oni na
základě toho voda nebo jaká by měla být
vyvolávací cena, kam až to bude stoupat?
To už jako čistě na tom obchodu jako
takovým, ale my už nemáme právo,
když začne ta aukce do toho zasahovat,
ani nemůžeme ty produkty stát.
Jedině že byste se mi pustili teoreticky
možná vlastně že budou stavovat cenu,
jestli jako řekneme, ano, to je asi dobrý,
tak abychom ho asi viděl, neříkáme to ne.
Jako můžeme se ještě o tom pobavit do
breaklot,
jako je to o tomhle dobrá zpráva. Jirik,
Jakub jsme prodali přestat starou
ještěrku, která ještě jako dokážu.
Jinak řečeno jo 300000 na vítáno hlínková
optávka substará prodala se super za 1
korunu.
Firma sro pancifian hubr.
Jako.
Ten přirozeně podezřívavý.
Jediný jako tohle byl.
Jednodušší no asi chápu z 2 strany to
neumíme vidět.
Takže je lepší než to vyhodit lepší ta
koruna.
Vidíš jakoukoliv větru z každého nosí
třídy metoda, kde to všechno,
kde tě můžou očůbrat ještě 1. Krásně.
Ale asi tak,
i to je jako bylo dobré zelenak jako
nějaký motor o tom že jo.
Ta požadavek.
Jo to ale budiž čistě na nás,
abychom dokázali odhadnout tu cenu. Nevím,
jestli pokud ne to dokáže.
A já se obávám, že to nedokážu.
Protože já to chápu, tak míra říká,
co nedokážeme prodat, pojďme vyhodit,
takže 0 je jakoby ta hranice,
nebo co je na míru cokoliv? Co je na to,
že nám to čeká,
že z toho skladu vysublimovat?
Podesát?
30000 to dostat jako ven.
Někam na opční too pod bránu ten má 2
prostitutky toho vidět aspoň.
Jo, jako počítám stoprocentně,
že budou věci, který budu muset.
Tak.
Budeme na další, tedy rma AQ cz do vtipků.
Super byl ve znamení připraven
infrastruktury.
Se zaměstnanci.
Nastavení doprav takhle bych to jako z
minulou rozvedu.
Během dubna jsme připravili komplet
značenou infrastrukturou kamery,
elektřina, internet.
Došlo k nějakým jako 1 setkání s
dodavateli přímo na místě.
Tak jako to tohle tomu budu pokračovat v
nexsteps co se týče hr tam už Radka Petra.
Ukončenej většina zaměstnanců je
podepsáno.
Problémoví zaměstnanci se stále řeší,
ale jsou to jednotky.
S problémem?
Kteří budou mít ten problém, protože.
Jsou to fakt jako 2 3 něco takovýho,
takže tohle považuju za úspěšný ze strany
hr.
Co se týče.
Procesáci teďka jako analyzovali to
nastavení přepnutí toho zpětného toku,
aby to jakoby plynuli nám z toho 2
otazníčky 1 otazníček je souvislnost sro.
Posílání servisních požadavků DPD do
servisu SK.
Se to jako posílá zkrášan,
protože DPD tam jezdí.
Nestojí to v uvozovkách nic.
Ve chvíli,
kdy budeme ve zdibech tak to RPD tam bude
muset servisním požadavkům jako takovým.
To znamená komercial oprav dostal
podklady,
do jaké objem se jedná a vyčíslí to a
jakmile budeme mít ty čísla,
tak si řekneme, co s tím dál.
Jak k tomu přistoupíme a nabízí se a
notebook box a dalších jako hromada
řešení potřebujeme teďka mít,
ale jako vůdce to,
co můžeme udělat ne do 1 7 a možná když
to bude jako.
Pro drahý,
tak nás to ve finále jako nakopne.
K tomu to třeba vyřešit jiným dopravcem
nebo jiným způsobem, nebo třeba.
2 0 taky tak jako.
Přesně tak přesně tak tam se.
Minimálně.
Ty servisy,
které jsou jako v okolí Praha střední
Čechy,
tak by byly jako super easy nad rok 2 0
posílat to těm servisům rovnou stříd.
A.
Takže toliko za ten duben co se týče
května. To,
co jsem tady zmínil jako nejdůležitější
infrastruktura schválené.
On si klienta máme vybrané dodavatele
máme schválený rozpočet a máme v plánu
instalace, aby bylo k 1, 7 9 s těmi,
co jsme se tam jako zatím potkali,
tak jsme si potvrzovali,
že 1 7 je za ně OK.
Pravděpodobně to za data bude dělat
miricom jak pro reversku,
tak pro rma to samozřejmě bod schválí.
A díky tomu, že to bude dělat mini com,
tak by ta příprava těch všech tras.
Na tu být jako velmi rychlá a.
Být jako bez problémů bysme s me to tam
procházeli na mě.
2.
Je to, co jsem tady zmiňoval.
Potřebujeme rozhodnuto,
jak tomuhle tomu přistoupíme a nebo
jestli tady jako v rámci toho odesílání
do servisu nějaká jako razantní změna,
tak jak jsem o tom teďka mluvil?
No to infrastruktura dojde třicátýho 5 co
schváleno nebo zahájuje instalace já nebo
co to znamená 30 baru.
No že máme máme schválený rozpočet,
to to vidíme jako největší na tenhle
břímě.
Tím,
že máme schválený rozpočet a máme jako
vytvořený objednávky dodavatelům,
tak máme potvrzeno,
že to 1 muset mít stihnu,
tak vy vlastně chceš jako začít
instalovat datum hlavně upřímně 1.
Kdy to začnu instalovat, když mi řeknou,
že to 1 7 bude.
Jo,
možná se ještě dostanu k dalším detailům,
co se týče reversky u, je to fakt jako 1.
Kdy začnou.
Dneska jsme se na place přímo s
mirikoulem domlouvali,
že by to udělali jako na více etap a
vždycky bychom jim na té na té plošině
nějakou vymezili tu část,
kterou zrovna budou dělat,
protože jsme se shodli na tom,
že ten provoz tady máte jako zastavit,
nemůže nahrání, nechceme.
Takže se to tam,
takže se to tam rozplánuje.
Zajímavost,
ty kabely nejspíš všechny povedou spodem
podlahou.
Spojí se to,
spojí se to iskabalama pro reversku.
Je to přání Honza šimáčka,
protože se to připravuje bez i na
kolaudaci a chtěl by to mít co nejčistší.
Takže na stropě je to příjemné. Jo,
přesně tak.
Ale je to přízemným stropem a vytáhne se.
Vytáhnou se do podlahy nebo tady formou.
Budou tam normálně ty jako rámy,
ale nebude to na té plošině vrchální do
té kolaudace.
Ta Vojtěch jo,
aby tam nebyly takové ty jako uchlance
kabelu.
Dneska jsem se byl podívat na reversce v
klášterech a tam je to jako zbastlené
různé jako prodlužovačkama a tak.
A tomu se chce jako on za Šimáček vypnout,
aby jsme to tam pak nemuseli předělávat.
No je to něco, co rozhodně budeme muset.
Jako.
Pravděpodobně tohleto řešení,
jako bude dražší,
ale ten argument IZ té kolaurace to je to,
proč se to takhle má 100.
OKA do toho 5 účet nových,
která to chce docela mít jako návrh nebo
jako rozhodnuto,
nebo chce ho mít rozhodnuto.
Jak to bude s tím, jak to bude s tím DPD,
respektive jak to bude s tím odesíláním
do servisu ze zip?
Něco jiného podobně.
Posílají jo čeho odesílání,
teda těch požadavků.
Dále,
co jsem tady samozřejmě všechno zmiňoval,
ale probíhá normálně jako realizace.
Podle toho harmonogramu,
kterej jsme si tam připravili,
řeší se tam úkoly typu zajištění jako
skříněk pro zaměstnance a tak dále.
Ale nemyslím si, že tohle je něco,
co bych v tomhle plénu jakoby teďka až do
konce, prostě přesně,
tak běžně no napíšu i tady.
Ty másy 7 členů každé je zodpovědnej za
nějakou jako danou oblast a zajišťuje se,
aby to všechno bylo.
Použitelný k tomu detaily takhle 3 3 3
takový mladíky jo.
Nebo všechno otázky rváčku.
Dobrý večer bereverzeno to už má možná
Ondra tam při těch KP ich narážel na ty
mšice a chtěl si k tomu něco říct,
protože tohle to já vím,
jako jsi chtěl řešit celkovou cílovou asi,
ale tady jsme se jako bavili s Davidem
petráše je otázka, byla,
jestli máme řešit sou souběžně jako v
tomhle projektu a informaci jsem dostal,
že ne řeší se to jako bokem.
Já tam tedy martinský,
že to tam 1 7 velká bílá nebo je tak?
Včera sro.
Logistický logistiku hele co to rma?
To jde.
A vlastně nevymysli mi z pohledu jako
ploch.
S tím počítám.
Nebo v užitcích věcí.
Jo myslím, že tam s ním počítáme.
Je tady videk.
Není podle mě a výtek spee.
Já myslím, že tam s tím počítáme,
protože my tam v tuhle tu chvíli už tu
plochu máme. Akorát míň používáme k tomu,
že tam skladujeme ledničky,
který následně posíláme do zdi místo toho,
abychom tam skladovali ledničky,
který následně vodesíláme tomu servisu,
nebo to, že to jako neni vo tom,
že by tam ta plocha narostla od minus
minu s tím se spojem jo,
nebo já si to jako klidně vezmu tady.
David tečka 3 týdny nebude,
tak já to klidně můžu jako s ním
proklepnout todleto.
Abys bychom to jako dohodněte se já si s
tím zavolám.
Právě potřebuji říct jako mírovi.
Evidentně jsme z toho jako teda vyřadili
s mírou to probíral právě novýtek no a
tak jsme říkali,
že se o tom domluvili dobrý den.
Které mi to říkal.
Ne že je to potvrzený, to je tolik korun.
Proč tak 2 má revize logistika by mohl
chráš ten jo.
Vesměs.
Podobný scénář,
protože samozřejmě tyhle ty 2 projekty
řešíme souběžně,
to znamená infrastruktura a dopravy.
Teďka jako konkrétněji k tomu,
co se stalo v dubnu v dubnu,
si tu roli vlastníka povídkově převzal
tady tom a,
kterej se do toho během pozná nějakým
způsobem dostával, aby zjišťoval,
jak jako raverská funguje a tak dále.
Takže Tomáš, že se na to vyhradil čas?
Přejdu rovnou k těm doprava.
Co se týče zase těch otazníků,
mluvil jsem o 1.
Teďka budu mluvit o 2 a to je zpětný tok
od malíkářů to znamená nevyslepnuté
objednávky odeslané z chrášťan a.
Prozatím ten výsledek je takový,
že umíme u každého z dopravců,
kterým posíláme zákazníkům na adresu,
nastavit zpětnou adresu jinou než adresu
vlastně jako chrášťan.
Teďka si to adam kyse narušilo s každým
tím dopravcem otáčí.
Bude to zřejmě složitější na.
Tohle jako procesní nastavení,
aby to od toho 1 osobní fungovalo.
To znamená teďka zase stejně nemilník.
Dokonce května potřebujeme mít potvrzeno
a už to za rok na procesní tým do práv,
aby měli minimálně 2 měsíce na to to
nastavit, otestovat a ujistit se,
že to skutečně funguje.
Abychom od 1 setu měli i balíkáře.
I balíkáře bez divec.
Vysoký náklady jsme je nutili jezdit si
pro ten zpětnej pro,
kdyby chtěli bysme nutili pozdit ten
zpětnej to dozním jo a údajně jako nejsou.
Údajně údajně je to jako v pohodě. Jo,
tohle je poslední zpráva od komeršlu.
Teďka jsme akorát s Tomem dávali
dohromady objemy a aby aby i ti dopravci
věděli.
Kolik to zhruba je a jak budeme mít
finále od Adama kysilky? Tak.
Ale tak to začnou procesáci nastavovat a
testovat.
Takže tam zůstane jenom redelivery a
ještě.
Potom jsme domluvení,
že už vlastně od začátku.
Přejdu ještě k infrastruktuře.
Vesměs podobný,
vlastně jako mnohem jednodušší,
než je rmačko,
protože ty pracoviště nejsou tak složité.
Nebudeme tam hrát žádný stlačený vzduch a
podobně. To,
co jsem si dneska na provozu všimnul ve
zdibech, je,
že celej ten prostor budoucí reverzní
logistiky je samozřejmě jako teďka
využívání logistikou.
Jsou tam zchladněné nějaké jako lednice.
Siguro je to fakt jako plný a nedá se tam
hnout.
To znamená.
Jakmile od dodavatele dostaneme jako
termín začátku těch prací,
tak se s vasilem potřebuju jako vsadit na
tom,
že ten prostor bude vyklizený to jako
nový.
Jo, bylo to nový zboží, bylo to,
bylo to nový zboží fakt jako nastavované
na paletách a.
To ta moje třeba něco tenkrát úplně nějak
málo a.
Na 2 stranu by teďka byl objedna se začít
opadat.
No a tak takže řekneš,
zastavíš informace nebo dodavatele?
Tehdy a tehdy přesně a na kolik potřebuje?
Teda pro sa to vyřízení zhruba.
Aby to dali pryč, to je více.
Prostě to musí říct předstihu. Ne? Jo,
určitě,
ale dneska jsem se to jako dozvěděl,
takže teďka jako půjdu za vastilem a budu
to času ale přesně zároveň miricom bude
potřebovat,
abychom jim tam na podlahu vyznačili ty
stoly,
protože ta instalace nebude prograstylem.
Máme stoly,
AK tomu přijde mirico nainstalovat jako
infrastrukturu,
ale my potřebujeme mít připravenou
infrastrukturu,
abychom pak přesunuli s Lukášem.
Tom jsou u stoli s chrášťan a už tam jako
rovnou začali fungovat. Jenom je zapojili.
To znamená oni to teďka potřebují jako
vyznačit na zem. Tohle je cvičení,
už jsme si jako vyzkoušeli ve skal c 3.
Relativně to jako funguje,
když ty pásky na té zemi drží, ale.
Třeba lepší pásky super toto,
ale samozřejmě zase na to vyznačení už
potřebujeme, aby tam bylo, aby to obrázek,
takže to nejde infrastruktuře.
To léto dodá se tam pane policii jo,
ale jenom jako zmíněný, že tohle dám.
Jenom knihovníka, co to bude jako řek,
kolik toho bude?
Ty manipulační,
co se hlá soupečně prohlásil to Vasil.
Nevím teďka z law,
jestli Tomáš někde na to, co měli program,
aby.
Dost ručních auťáků na 1 paletu a 1
elektrický nízko zdvih.
Jo.
Tak jo 1.
No počkej tam je to tam ještě vosu stolů.
To bude vypadat pro koho?
Ale celkem bude v přízemí na revers ce 46
pracovišť.
AV patře na adminu 12.
OK edura obsluhovat to jestli ti palanďák
máte dál, má to málo hodně nebo?
46.
Ale pokud potřebuje 10 baleťáků,
tak já mu jako věřím.
Já to nemám jako věřit.
Tuhle tu informaci,
jako jestli jsi zjistil,
že dneska na reversku potřebuji ka v
paleťáku, tak asi bych jako tohle.
Fázi proč kolik al kolik?
Máte?
Je to dixovaný.
Jsou tu třeba pro ty panely.
Koho tam načtený?
A kolik Tomáš stani?
Chesport.
Správnou 160. 32.
502 nebo 32.
Nus.
Tak když jsou potom jako.
Ti jsou bokem ve návštěva.
Pak 46 a 10 paligátů jo.
Podržme, že to je málo hodně,
nebo tady uvidím nějaký jako alarm z toho,
co říkal vlastně David, tak chápu,
že to vlastně možná lehce naddimenzoval
vlastně.
Spíše ale jako jestli to je o 1 kvaliťák
tak je to 1.
To bych tady jako to radši ať to nemám o
1 paleťák jedně u nich jako proč proč?
13 jo vědět.
Protože i kdyby to bylo na stříli,
bylo to fajn. Jo, chvilku.
Nebo tak úžasný poměrně všechny pracovní
je jako pár 100 malostí a.
Dobrý sejf.
A.
Tak a to, co tady máme stále otevřeno,
je beneq na mastev upravy tome,
jestli okomentuješ stavu, prosím tím,
že vlastně dojde k tomu přesunu.
Na jinou dobu, tak si nevyřešit i ten.
Systémový přesun potom v té třídě dny na
ty sklady,
kde to budeme zaskladňovat ten zpětný to.
Na to mám sepsané zadání,
už jsme ho i představili it a dneska ve 4
hodiny s nima mám schůzku,
kde budeme probírat, protože se to jeví,
jako že to.
Nebude tak jako úplně easy easy úprava,
takže.
Budeme probírat to jako velká kapacita by
na to byla potřeba eventuelně i tříd jako
z alternativ řešení,
které nebude potřeba tak velký zásah.
Bude jako skoro třeba bez práce, nevím.
Takže dneska od té čtvrteční z tohodle
pohledu chytřejší.
Takový velký politic za co tady to co
tady u it stránku.
Jinak se nám tam jako neobjevili.
Jsme třeba i procesy byly vyžadoval
nějaký zásadní zástupce, takže bylo dobrý.
Jo,
ale jediný co tak já já se pořád jako
potom myšlenkama vracím zpátky k tomu
našemu tomu workshopu,
kde jsme se jako vydefinovali.
Spoustu jako změn,
pak bychom asi měli být schopni si to
nějak jako zpětně odečíst,
co se neudálo proč? Protože jakože,
protože ty plány na začátku byly,
jako si říct jako megalomanské,
ale jako měli jsme to namyšlené docela
jako velkým, tak pak si odečteme,
co z toho se prostě jako stalo a co jsme
třeba okamžili. Vlastně vypočítavo s tím,
že to bude prostě dodělat,
protože když se tykateli středa 46 + 12.
Tak.
Budem pokračovat takhle,
tak vzhledem k potkáme 55 + 12 tu auto 15
další rok to bude jako 70 + 20 jo.
To bylo, směje se vymyslet jo,
možná si třeba udržet dokážou nějak jako
pomoct už na webech?
Ale proto prostě jsme se dneska bavili s
Tomášem tak to nenaskladňovat,
tak naskladňovat to asi nebylo to
potvrzová. Tak to musíme jako vymyslet.
OK.
Milníky.
Tasy tady jsem o tom už mluvil.
Potřebujeme,
potřebujeme potvrzení o těch dopravců,
že jo OK změnit zpět na adresu ú všech
dobrý dokonce.
Beru tohle jako mohuníky do konce května.
Jo, možná jo jo,
možná někde jako nastavíme nějaké jako
dřívější datum,
ale třeba u té infrastruktury je to dost
jako trefit to na den.
Je do konce května.
Taky do konce května tady jsem dal zájem
vývoj má zde náslačilo.
Už už to fakt jako dokončit a to,
protože zároveň jsem si,
jako že pokud nezačneme jako během
tohohle měsíce už něco prodat,
tak jako nestihneme vůbec nic.
Podle mě tak to asi nebude moc schopná.
To bude asi dřív, ne,
ta konci klienta musí mít zájemky,
volit konce klid a musí být zájem a pak
mají hrát měsíc, jo, včetně testingů.
Že jo jenom vývoj zájem.
Pak to jako.
Když to ještě nezačíná nějak analyzovat,
to je bajka stůj co stůj bart měsíc.
To potřebujete.
A už se s nima nějak mluvil o kapacitách?
Kapacitách jsme dneska to řeší s dneska
vybrali lásku,
protože podle toho prvotního představení
z toho jako vzešlo,
že to vypadá jako náročně.
Kapacitně to není,
že možná půjde třeba na jinou cestu vařit
tam.
No dobře.
Tak dokonce května, že jo jsi říkal,
že jo.
Ano ten rozpočet viní palace,
stejně tady je samozřejmě přibude ještě
ten singl z hasilem.
Asi bychom měli připravenej ten prostor,
aby tam 1 7 nebyl.
Anagram příprava harmonogram přesunu do
kdy jo,
ale tady já se no taky nepotřebuju to do
konce měsíce,
nebo respektive během května jako udělat,
abychom to teďka věděli,
aby Lukáš v tom sapočítal s tím,
že se budou musetovat nějaké stoly. Lukáš,
v tomsa se jako hlásil k tomu,
že toho ochotně jako chce řešit.
Takže předpokládám,
že to budu řešit s ním.
Lukáš kumsa dokonce chtěl tahat mi ty
kabely, no tak já to má jako něco užili,
ale minimálně si mysleli nám jako může
pomoct, protože co se týče expanze.
Jak tam moc není?
Tohle je jako zdravit logistiku ano.
Prosím tě,
tady jsem vám stoly na SO 0 1 2 3.
Takže tam chceme postavovat tu noc?
Někde jako materiál.
Stoly za dejme tomu 200 kilo odeslat.
Se přidám,
že petring forem stejně se bude po mě
jako další stol. Já si myslím,
že to tam máme.
Se vrátím, tak kolik děkuji generálům,
pojďme dál, rozumím.
A ještě ty administou tě zaučení je
adminů,
ale tohle to jsme tady měli jako tak nám
to tady zatím málo.
Teďka jsem to tady dal do těch milníků.
Potřebuji zjistit,
kdo je vůbec jako garant to zaučení,
jestli to má být pro něj,
kdo to vlastně jako zrealizuje s těmi
současnými admini?
Bezdiberche respektive ten náš tanec,
takže tady já potřebuji teprv jako
zorientovat,
co je vlastně jako cílem toho zaškolení.
A kdo ho bude dělat?
Ten no.
Je to má primárně dělat z broni dává
největší smysl. Nemá to, přišlo jo,
ale zrovna teď broňa definovali ty
pracoviště vlastně pro ty adminy.
Potvrdili jsme si,
že těch 12 pracovišť co tam bude OK,
tak asi jich tam bude jako 10.
+ 2 budou booming. Myslím si,
že on by měl asi řešit to školení.
Pobyt 4 teda věci jo klíčových 5.
Člověk věcí jo jo.
Po 2 či se začnou jako délky?
Je toho dost.
A tak pošleme pomalu do finále?
Jo jo a jako teď už potřebuje.
Jde to vlastně to jako to delivery přesun
data. Jako hlavně jde o to,
aby nám v čas udělali tu infrastrukturu a
ještě prosím říkám shimi,
kde tak on se bude v tom v těch hele a
kolaudace je výhledově shimi ani nedokáže
říct,
jestli to bude letos nebo příští rok,
protože ještě jakoby hraje na úřadech
nějak tam to předpokládám,
vstupuje ta lékárna a to tam jako nejsem
v detailu,
ale neohrozí to náš stát 1 se mi telefon
máte zmrazit prostě.
No dobrý den, pojďme dál.
Děkujeme.
Tak vám ti prostě na tebe, to je má den.
A musí dělat drahé.
Jo jo.
OKDP Plzeň a co se udělalo nejdůležitější?
Řekneme v dubnu,
i když to mallo pres do května, tak.
Podepsání nájemní smlouvy a převzetí
vlastně budovy.
Odsouhlasili jsme si layout.
Finálně včera na místě s vasilem,
kterej tam byl poprvé,
takže se seznámil s prostorem.
AA vlastně všechno důležité se musí
odehrát teďkon v květnu.
Abysme 18 mohli spustit testovací provoz.
Takže všechno je v podstatě v procesu.
Jediné,
co tak Vasil ještě půjde zpátky na Ondru
ohledně nízko divných vozíkou,
protože ty je jsme v rozpočtu,
protože jsou na dovybavení toho depa a va
to považuje za za riziko. Takže počítám,
že s tím prý za ondroum,
ještě aby se to prodiskutovalo.
Jakým způsobem bysme to udělali?
OK.
Tak to je asi za mě de po Plzeň v tady to
chvíli.
Až teď.
Jsou,
já si já s tím prohraju a případně se
ozvu jo. Tady tady se na to podívám tady,
jako jsou.
Jo klidně.
Jo 18. 5 dobře a po 18. 5.
Není žádný to prostě zkusíte a budete
pozorovat. Jo 18.
A po 18 5 máme už rempub,
ale ten padá zase do června.
OKV pohodě, děkuju.
Tady je asi jasný druh mé téma téma
pokrytí třídící dat.
Říkám.
Tam je větší, tam je,
tam je vždycky větší sranda.
Petr petr petr.
Tak pojď.
AS.
A jak to říct?
Plán máme,
že bysme příští týden spustili hosín.
Chtěli jsme tenhle týden,
posouvalo se to kvůli nasazení toho life
kvalicrosom.
Novej bydžov včera no.
Ano.
V podstatě jako ta trasa,
která zafungovala, tak ta třídit lze.
Jediný problém, který tam vidím já,
tak je tam to pokrytě slabé.
Potřebujeme tam posilnit infrastrukturu,
protože doteďka tam byla jenom na XLA.
Ty čtečky reagovaly pomalu,
ale má možná tu cenovku.
Vyvolal jsem razítko,
musím ještě na míru poprosit,
aby se to tam dodělalo příští týden a
můžeme to spustit.
AA pak bysme šli do vratimova.
Jako že tam je samý AP.
Ano ano je tam jsou tam slabé AP,
protože oni byli umístěné jenom na ty x
lkové gay, takže jako pokrytí tam máš,
ale když naskenuješ ten kód,
tak to prostě pod roh skenovat vypadne a
čekáš tam. Já nevím minutu,
než to zase naskočí, takže je to špatný.
Ale já už jsem to rozporovala dopředu.
Já jsem tu informaci má dopředu,
takže dneska mi pristala cenovka.
Jo,
to znamená to znamená ty milníky na
A.
příští měsíc jsou.
I 14 15 spoustě těch hosín 22.
Pustit bigeo.
Spustit Plzeň a na konci května se
vrhnout na vrativnov,
Tak přesně tak.
takže bychom měli mít spuštěný 3 DA
připravenej vrativost.
Tak.
Fer.
Konec a komika teda jo,
ale ten po Teplice třeba to 9 gib takže.
Jo je v ostatních nebech potvrdíme si
sídlo wifiny.
Vrátíme ho, máme potvrzený od Michaela.
Gottwalda, který tam byl AS čtečkou,
se prošel. Je to tam funkné.
AA my jsme vlastně bi jo malý potvrděný
jo, my jsme už věděli dopředu,
že to tam slabí.
Ale včera ten problém byl primárně o tom,
že byly blbě nastavený trasy.
Ano prosím.
Já jakože v této chvíli nemám odpověď,
jestli byly nastavené blbě tím člověkem,
který to nastavoval a nebo tam má vliv na
to. Jo OK, tak Ondra kývá hlavou, vidím,
Které.
A to je teďka ale hnedka jako 1 to se
stane, to se tam davide, kdybych udělal,
takže byly.
to nám nějaký ****** na skladu si nemáš
představit, to je.
Dobrý den, tak jdeme dál,
pak just děkujeme za dál.
Máme posledních pár minut jo.
OK.
No, případně protáhneme.
No my s terkou potřebujeme utéct na ten
GM jenom dobrý bitva 310000 bez práce
teda nemusíš celý rok a griom high i jo,
což jsou proběhlo minulý měsíc nebo co
bude tento měsíc?
Já si jenom že shrnutí jenom se stalo.
Hele slibuji ti věci se stalo nebo proč
si odešleš?
Byli jsme na referenci v Německu ohledně
toho vynestu robota, prošli jsme si to.
Zinte si potom tře trojku a řekli jsme si
nějaký, jak se společně s Martina,
kde jsem tomácnul tu a nebo ne,
doma jsem si to nebo ne hlavní baví se to,
že zatím zatím ne jsme si dali,
tam je ten nákup a zatím jsme si zajistit,
abysme to tam bylo zapůjčení toho rohodle.
Já se jako 1 velká věc,
potom dokončení všech těch datových a
reportových reportů na věc ke sledování.
Tohle se prý.
Tam započítávám i report pro příjem a
úsporu,
který jsem procházel zejména v ale s,
který jenom vzešel seznam akčních kroků
jak chování ku tak abychom výši
projektivitu nebo katastrofa blízkost.
My jsme si rozdělili,
rozdělili při něm vlastně na pastiny.
Zjistili jsme, která směna dobrá včera,
která pokuhává a potom spolu.
Dá se takové roky.
To řešení, co tam bylo důležitý?
Zavedli jsme náhodou sporu pravidelný
kontroly,
protože se dělá sám provoz nebo stoupá se
v tom sou, který jsou diplom za týden.
K tomu, aby ten hardware optimálním stavu,
abych teda.
To máme počítačů a tak dále.
Lepší stížnosti, ale kolik tu bubliku?
Další, co jsme si tam procházeli,
jestli budu v 5 přemýšlej schvále,
jsme si na tom partnerů a letos tento
týden začínáme s objednáváním.
To asi ještě důležitý byly ještě aspoň
pak teplou situaci, která byla úsporu.
To znamená, že nebo tím občas ztrácely.
Signály se zasahovali společně společně s
elementem listopad do 4. Dostal do sporu,
že byla ta situace určitě došlo taky
hotová a to už je to je úplně vyřešený a
už se na to vůbec nestává.
Dostáváme těch nových robotech,
nebo stále o tom,
co jsme přidali těch 150 tich robot,
abychom.
Jako nestává se to,
že by roboti už to ne aby tomu stalo to
jako že?
A stalo se to začalo to, protože já vím,
že jsem to na začátku a teď jsem to začal
řešit znova,
tak ten stav byl pořád stejný a nebo se
to změnilo potom,
co jsme přidali 150 roků 1 se mi o to,
jestli na to máme až přidáno těch 80
další.
Co jsme teď procházeli AIS tím ipem s
autosou tak problém.
Tady už máme ty už jsme tady ani třeba
moso s napadnou v rámci toho stejně.
Tady tohlencto přijde,
to tam bylo ještě něco většího.
Asadili jsme pár menších století it a to
asi nestojí za zmínění.
Ta asi je to důležité, aby se stalo lehce.
Pokud ji chceš tančit,
co se týká tý stavby,
tak proběhl kecal selementem někdy před
14 dněma.
Zahájili jsme stavební připravenost
proporty. Máme nějaký harmonogram prací,
proběhly koordinační schůzky s těma
profesemi a teďkáme na cenovky.
Tak nějak, co se stalo v týhletý oblasti,
když to převedu na to, co nás čeká,
tak v pondělí se budeme dolaďovat s ela
mantem harmonogram těch jednotlivejch
prací.
Potřebujeme si podle cenovek nechat
schválit rozpočet pro stavební přípravu a
ty práce v tunelu máme naplánovaný na
posledních 14 dnů v květnu,
protože bysme chtěli 1 6 romanů předávat
připravenej prostor tunelu na.
Na to, aby mohl začít dělat ty prostupy.
Craneta jo 15 5 jo.
Jo.
A ten rozpočet ten rozpočet pro cestuál
grip jste v ní přípravu kdy ten deadline?
Tu kapsilíte?
Tak ty schůzky byly tento týden.
I minulý týden žádnou cenovku zatím
nemáme,
tak to cílíme tak maximálně nějakého 18
dvacátýho května.
Když se na bavíme dvacátýho,
tak stihneme tu přípravu dokončit do
dvacátýho devátýho.
To, jako když to vezmeme odzadu,
jak to sedí.
Máme tam buffer jak pro tak,
případně i na ty odstraňovací práce s
promanem jsme se domlouvali,
že případně oni můžou u toho 1 6 začít na
jedný straně to tunelu a na 2 straně
ještě můžou probíhat,
případně ty odstraňovací práce,
který by se tam nestíhal,
že v tomhle v tomhle tom jsme se dohodli
na nějaké koordinaci od 4 milníky,
šty datumy. Teďka máme, to je v pohodě,
pak jsme doplnili tam být 18 5.
Mám to trapná ty nebo kolikátý to
třináctýho teda osmnáctýho je pondělí tak
tady osmnáctýho, tak jo,
a ty datum neříkej.
Tady sou to sou nějak ještě trošku trošku,
což jsou vzdálená. Něco nás čeká pětku,
dalšího zvětšujeme picker a nebo 600 lidí
to vládí aji na tom úplně Adéla tam
chepsej. Co se týče chatu,
tam se teďka stejně dobou,
tak stejně kvůli automatickýmu lese.
Stav připojení se.
Nám tam nepřijíždějí, odjíždí berdy,
protože tam se stačíme do kouta,
protože tam potom důležitý budu
připravovat z autu spolu discovery.
V podstatě se jedná o to, že nám přijeďte,
sjednáme si, spoustu má zákazně,
má postup,
který samozřejmě odražení jako vy.
Třeba velký austor má dobrou moje vlastní
BM sro a pokusíme se s nima navázat
nějakou hlubší spolupráci a navázání to a
další represe a tak dále.
Jedná se v podstatě o to,
abychom věděli 1 moc ne nějaký punč várky
a.
A aby slovník masáž byl na nějaký byt,
respektive spol na ten prostor.
Čili to je podle mě tam důležitý s Pavlem
sočičkovou jsme připravili nebo
připravili na vypravení, aby.
O budecké medi vydávaly pomoc.
Signalizaci to může původní z projekťák
je koupil.
Testy zvuků signalizace,
tak se do toho tak to mohlo být,
aby jsme to věci vydávalo počítač a
dneska dám.
Stát to vyjde.
Doufám,
že s morisem konečně vykopnu tena s Intel.
Tam se jedná o to,
že pomůžem AI lepší lepší automatizaci
cestovou uděláme tam ty dálnice na
lakouspodu a tak dále. To by mělo zlepšit.
Stejně jako změny mají zájem zrychlit
testy do popu.
Žitý.
A co jste mi ještě podařilo s tou
posporem,
nebo by bylo pro vašeho graf speciální?
AS on říká jako na internet excela.
Servisní technice salphoru bych řekl
nějaký lepší nejlepší servis na to,
jak se dostanu.
Každý jsou akorát aktivity nějaký ten
plus míst taky tam dole není trhu do
dejme, prosím tě.
To je všechno jako milníky.
Tolik byly věci, no a nebo třeba,
jako je to v balíčku, když to je balíček.
Jo.
No, to je o tobě OK?
Já potřebuju běžet ten gen bych chtěl
všem poděkovat za tu přípravu a jenom.
Takový jako malý upozornění,
který si všimla v posledních letech
květen,
je takovej jako rizikovej měsíc z pohledu
toho, že se nám zdá,
že jsme ještě jako daleko od sezóny,
ale my už jsme ji jako strašně blízko,
tak jenom upozorňuju na to,
abychom jako nezpomalili,
nezaspali a neuteklo nám to z tohohle 2
měsíce,
ale 2 měsíce to naskladňovací sezóny a
pak měsíc do nebo 2 měsíce do do do sn
taky docela 2 měsíce napsal do měsíce
prázdnin vin nic nikdo neudělá.
Protože strašný na prem potkávat,
pak jo tak jenom z tohodle pohledu.
Už je to jako za dveřma.
Měli bysme finalizovat těch projekt,
jak to tak vypadá, tak jenom,
ať to k tomu směřujeme a evidujem to,
že byť je to jako 0 5,
tak pro nás z toho pohledu směrem k
sezóně je to jako za dveřma.
Děkuju, to je ještě poprosila,
aby vám ještě do projedete pravděpodobně.
Já se vrátím na 2 tejdny a děkuju
dovolená dívej.
Užili tak pojďme dál. Ještě prosím,
že teda skočím na další přímý kapacita
příjmu 20 26 a dáme výroby slovo já vás
potřebuju taxík. Teda já se přiznám,
že už je to za tý manipulací.
Co vám můžu jenom manipulačka asi příští
týden tak ještě do tady chrášťany číslo,
jestli bůh ví něco objednat,
protože tam se bohužel nějaký pronájmy.
A ta 2 věc, ty člověk se s Davidem,
protože on jako je s Davidem jsem si přál
jo on říká,
že nebo já jsem dneska pochopil na přímou
komunikuju s torotou,
taky mi to řekla píčo.
Já nevím jestli to je OK.
Potřebuji jenom banksitek pro jistotu, že?
No já jsem pochopil s touto,
komunikuje to rušení těch nájmů.
A ne jako nějakej nákup OK,
tak prosím nejenom tohleto si to musím
udělat,
neřeší nic jako třeba ohledně nákupu
případného a žádné služby.
Maximálně na to,
jestli on ticond dohaduje zrušení hodinku,
respektive odkud těch současných,
tak to ať jako vám dodá.
Jo ale máme Davida a on je strašně
šikovný.
Dám mu tady to ray může strašně něco.
Jako jste říkal,
že bylo to samé problém a vždycky.
To nesmí udělat jo a se štočkama se
položil už Tomáš udělal nějaký nápočet,
ale tam čekáme ještě na čísla.
Jakou představu mají třeba slovenský
sklady?
A ještě víc tam chybí jejich čísla,
aby se to jako prodalo,
aby ten výpočet byl mimo.
A teď nevím,
jako jestli něco spěcháte z toho, nebo ne,
ale nebojíš se uh a myslím,
že příští týden se to a vlastně.
Tiskárny se jenom tiskárně přišli přece
jenom ta quickals.
Je to poptaný z minulého týdne od
dokumentu poslouchám tě čau.
Jo ramso.
Zítra já tak pokažte do toho teda já,
když ty kapacity 20 26.
Příjem.
No tak tam máme dokončenej schválený
layouty pro prašťany pro růžice.
Chybí nám ještě zdiby to mám odmítka
přislíbeno zítra,
že po těch depech se tam dostane.
Bude tam tomu věnovat celý den,
takže kromě layoutu s dětmi dodá i layout
pro bataho stanice a nějaký dodání se
cílovýho počtu stanic,
že teďka jich tam má 6 a.
Potřebujeme vědět,
kolik jich tam určitě abysme je mohli
natáhnout infrastrukturu pro ten přesun
abysme začít s tím přesunem.
Současně probíhá práce na na it vývoji.
Ještě jsme s Ondrou otevřeli minulý týden
řešení té ergonomie,
jestli vlastně budeme,
budeme měnit něco aktuálně na těch
portech nebo ne,
takže to je taky jako potřeba rozseknout.
A jestli budeme mít pevný nebo mobilní
pracoviště u toho trojeportu.
To je řešení trojkontů, je tady takový?
Ne to samé.
Zmíněný to má ve frontě Pavla růžičková.
Prosím to já tady potřebuju.
To je jako, to je velkej problém,
protože my pak nemá.
Není schopný tohoto človečka.
Co je na stanici.
Takovou vlastně vůbec nebýt teto do práce.
Jo a teďkon jako je.
Nevím kde vede, je to do sezóny,
je to na 3 týdny sezony.
3 měsíce.
Jo a prostě přežijí to,
protože to je 5 stanic 5 lidí.
A nebo navopak je to jako nonstop potřeba,
abyste se to přijít.
Tak jsem ho naši světovou už jako si to,
co přesně máte fíčura po rozdělení ale
stanice?
Stanice příjmové.
Ale stanice otáči jenom o 2 fotbale.
Zvuku.
11.
No jakoby nebo.
Tam jsou právě takový, jakoby 3 promiň.
Spíš si pak jako mám otázku,
jestli na těch stávajících trojporucích
je musíme chceme dělit se,
jako bych si ports.
Úplně stejná otázka.
Jsme řešili právě že prosím dořešte si to.
Myslím si, že jo, protože inventura je,
protože všechno ostatní jako věci a ta
sezóna bude dlouhá.
Nemůžu vypnout inventuru.
Solidaci nemůžeš vypnout na dýl než na x.
Zvláště se toho hodně.
Jo tam to jako vypadá,
že ten it vývoj tam chceme,
ale teďka jako ještě potřebujeme vyřešit,
jestli tam chceme nějaký pevný pracoviště,
nebo ten mobilní stolek,
když budeme mít ty porty na tom západě.
5 mobilních stopků na měsíc a půl je to
správně řešení jo AI,
přesto jako pak to se.
Ok vám dostanou editko.
A tady.
Martine.
Se to zařadil do protein.
Ů spousta.
To je dobrý tak?
Hele a ten kdo na květen dokončí schválně
no cz ta je teda ta cz do kdy teda to už
je jako to si mám zp paměti,
že by to ještě kolikrát posouvá?
Co tam je to způsobené tím,
že vyteknutá v noci po depech?
Takže úplně na to na to neměl prostor.
Jak jsem říkala,
tam to úplně nesouvisí jako nějak,
že by nás to nakopalo v tom projektu
nepředpokládáme tam žádný jako stavební
úpravy,
jde už jenom o tu conovat si ty plochy,
takže tam už to jakoby nebrzdí.
Termín tam být středu a to už snad ve
finále.
Říkám vám to přislíbeno,
že to udělá zítra a nechci tam dávat
úplně zítra dávat tady stejně ty 13.
Jo.
Připravovali infrastruktury a přesun BPL
stanic.
No.
Celý ten přesun toho bu PI potřeba udělat
do konce měsíce.
To lidi potřebujete pevného pracoviště u
trojbodu, třeba i hardware.
To je to tam.
Konec května, nebo?
Rozhodnutí. Potom to souvisí, že budeme,
když tak potřeba nakoupit nějakej
hardware v průběhu,
který nás jsme chtěli udělat nějakej ten
přímej stast test,
takže tam by to rozhodnutí mělo bejt tak
do nějakýho dvacátýho května.
Cátýho 5.
Nemělo by tam vadit, protože ta plocha,
kde už jakoby není tam tam jako není.
Už jo nejsou tam ty regály potom.
Vlastně na tý ploše teďka bude tam palety.
Bylo to zaskládaný paletama.
Včera jsem tam byla už tam jako těch
palet je relativně míň, je to pohled na.
To není.
To to jakoby já nepotřebuju na ten na ten
příjem potřebuju jako nebo procesovat.
Přestaň se.
To je teďka,
potřebuju několik těch slavných bude,
aby vlastně se mohla natáhnout na táhnout
ještě a vlastně se do mojí koláše samců
na přesunu těch stolů.
Dobře.
Současně tam řeším teda to otočení toho
výtahu, kolik by to stálo,
to jsem poptala, ale zatím nemám cenu,
takže nemám. Nemám vlastně jakoby co,
co se schvalovat teďka.
Po té schůzce jak připsat?
Všechno tam tady to rozhodnutí,
to dej taky dvacátýho.
To souvisí s tím hardwarem.
Zda by to fungovalo do konce měsíce.
Ještě tenhleten výtah ne rozhodnuto to
víte u nás.
Posunu ital ať už to bude jakkoliv a nebo
ne ne že jo.
Je to strašná jako od toho dodavatele to
bude nějaká část.
Řešíte s nějakým posunem toho lau?
Takže asi asi taky konec měsíce.
Takhle,
když jako potřebujem to vědět dřív,
ale teďka nedokážu ti říct,
nedokážu to přesný datum.
Když chceš, aby to bylo.
Jako projekťák.
Abys to měla,
protože to na to nějaké věci, že jo,
asi nějaká případná instalace,
nebo nějaké rozhodnutí peníze. Nevím, co.
Jenom tobě víš, co že bys to dělal,
aby to nějak se po tom plánu? Já to nevím,
tak se to ptám, rozumím.
Od toky 20.
A stihneme to potom jako třeba případně
upravit. Víte, co docela David?
Ka z toho dlouho nebyla, že jo.
Tak si myslím,
že se předem jenom dveře to nebude o
útočená z výtahu, ale bylo o tyto,
jak jsme se bavili o robotické je to tam,
je to praktické, to bylo to robotložit.
Protože jak budou mít čas no taky.
A je to jen o tom dveře.
Příklad, že nedopravní,
ale i dopravník to mi není tak není.
To mi jenom ten prožívám třeba mimo říkal
ne dopravník ne a najednou to i dopravní
ne 9 tedy.
V tuhle.
A člověk.
Zajímavý mě to jako zaujalo,
jenom když si to pamatuju viru lapy.
Dobrý tak jo tak do dvacátýho 5 byste
potom mohli dát?
Ano.
Tam to do.
Tak.
David Ondřej k tomu něco tady asi.
Tak jo tak jsme na konci tady tady není,
pane nějakého individuální.
Tak jo, děkuju.
Abych se do toho ten přeporučoval,
přemýšlím o tom.
14.
Pozdě nebyl, nebyl,
nebyl záměr sebe obavy, která 30 berete,
jsem poznal, on máš nějakou zónu?
400 se ti to asi nějak jako dobrý,
možná je z toho tak jo.
Moc děkuju.
A.